Yep, yep, that's on your side, it's different, and on our side, it's like, and it's way too hot. Eddie can tell you and everything about it, right, Eddie? Just give me a moment then.
Hmm.
The.
Yeah.
Oh.
Good morning, everyone.
Yeah.
Morning, everyone.
How's the house, Ashley?
It's good. It's coming along. Boxes everywhere.
I'm uh working on my office today, my.
Gotta get that set up.
I can hear the it sounds like a lack of.
Picture, like you know, it sounds like, you know, like, like you're in an empty, like an empty room.
A lack of stuff. It's very echoing.
Correct.
It's okay. At least I know it'll be it's permanent this time.
Hey, sorry guys.
Okay, so yeah, before we start, Addy, if you just want to, you know, start with things on the NOC end, and then I can take over. Thanks.
Thank you, Evan. So I think NOC part is pretty sorted. Evan, any feedback for us?
The only thing I would say is I want to continue to encourage the our three ITBD people to
to reach out to. So we're having an issue where someone will put in a ticket for a company and then...
Mhm.
The person who's getting contacted is the main contact for the company rather than the person who put in the ticket. I've gotten a couple calls on that of like, why are they calling me? And so typically it's when, I don't know, it might have to do just do with our system not having the right numbers in there, but
Um, um...
Just make sure when the ticket comes in that we're trying first to reach out to whoever put in the ticket.
Okay.
not calling the main contact on the company and asking them to be forwarded. So one of the feedbacks I got was like, they're always calling me and asking me to forward to this person, but.
you know, like this would be a company that has, that doesn't have a receptionist. It's just someone else in the company that they're calling. So I think we talked about that internally. I think we're going to be working on that. But the other, yeah, the other thing, the other, yeah, just one other thing before I forget, like,
Well, yeah, I think it's some sorry, but I was just...
The I continue to see where like a ticket can't be worked on because they're like, hey, I tried to contact you and I couldn't.
A lot of times they don't need to talk to the person in order to work on the ticket. So I think we're doing better on that. We talked about it last time, but just keep working on that. That's something that would be my feedback. Other than that, I think, you know, most of the most of the feedback is pretty good. I mean, you know, we've got one client who
Mm.
Um...
I'm talking about R360 guys. They're like, can you make sure that only Jeremy or Nolan handles our tickets, please?
Mhm.
That kind of stuff, you know, I mean, some clients are just goofy like that, but...
Um...
But I am, that is one of the feedback that I got back from R360 is like, you know, Jeremy or Nolan, great. The other people, sometimes they're good. Sometimes they don't know what the problem is. It takes too long. So I don't know. I mean, it's, like I said, overall, I think
Mhm.
They're doing really good, but...
Oh.
All right. Thank you, Vince.
I was just going to follow up to Ben's thing is that I think part of it too, and it's not just them, it's all our whole team, need to read through the ticket, number one when assigning, but also when working on it and making sure they adjust the contact on the ticket if it's not correct.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Yep, then that is noted. I'll I'll cascade the social team.
Yeah, I had the same problem. I'll look at a ticket, I'll look at the details on the ticket, and I'll just start working on it. And then, oh, wait a minute, the contact is wrong, you know, and I just have to make a habit of checking the contact and making sure that it's.
Mm-hmm.
That.
that it's correct. But yeah, I mean, I've been reviewing some tickets. I think the notes that are getting put in there are real nice and usually pretty informative. So I think it's, I think we're doing pretty good.
It's.
Mhm.
Yeah, so when point taken, I'll cascade this to the team and we'll make sure this will not happen again.
Okay.
Yeah, and then just make sure we, you know, emphasize that if they feel like a ticket is dragging or customers getting annoyed, just...
Ask for help. It's not a problem to ask for help.
Yep.
My only other thing I wanted to say, and then I'll stop talking, is I have been coming up with some things for Annie to work on after hours. I'm kind of finalizing some checklists and things. So I should have that ready by the end of this week. Some things like here are some regular after hours things that can be done as far as
checklist, like, you know, pick, I'm even, I have a thing where I might pick one client per week, maybe two.
depends on how quickly she can get through them and then just kind of go through that client on this checklist and things that were, you know, things that make sure that there'll be certain things to say, do I have their, you know, this in their documentation? Like for instance, do I have their Wi-Fi?
information coded? Do I have their ISP? Things like, just things like that that I've been kind of doing some cyber reviews. And when I go to the customer, that's when I catch these things that are missing, either from documentation or something we're supposed to be doing that we're not. I'd rather do that more often than not. So like I'm only checking it once a year.
If we could get, so let's say we have 100 customers, if we could check one or two.
Mm.
every day we might get, they might each cut client might get kind of checked over three or three times a year rather than once a year. So anyway, I'll keep working on that.
Yep, yeah.
Okay.
Thank you. Thank you, Ben. I think to be honest with you, you just stole my words because I was about to cover this piece, but that's okay. But before we jump in on our side, anything from the NOC end, did we cover everything? Otherwise, we can let them go and we can continue with our side.
Yeah, I think NOC part is going okay. I still want to try to get, we need to get our Halo, like when tickets come into the NOC, they're not, that I need to look at. I mean, I get these, I get emails that say like, you know, resource assigned.
Mmh.
And that's my name, but I don't think originally when a NOC ticket would come in that I need to look at, it would create a ticket in ConnectWise. And then we got off of ConnectWise and it didn't happen. But now we're on Halo and I think we're not.
hooked up or something. Like, you know, if there's a ticket that I need to look at, I don't think our systems are linked anymore.
So, I mean, just to be sure about Halo.
We.
And.
I know you switched from your previous BS it to Halo.
Mhm.
So do you still need support with Halo? Because from our side, we can do our best to support you with Halo. But you just need to.
Well, I think we need to a couple things. I mean, if you had like a Halo consultant who could we could buy some time from to like sit with us, I mean, Ashley's doing a pretty good job, but I mean, we have other things that
Yeah.
Exactly.
Maybe we would...
I don't know, maybe someone just to kind of review how we're doing. I don't know, I asked you, how do you feel about that?
No, I mean, I agree. I think there's some things that we probably aren't doing that we should be doing, or maybe we're not doing correctly.
I'm talking about like, so there's a company here in Atlanta called Decision Digital and their whole consulting, they used to be an MSP like this, but now their whole consulting practice, the whole entire thing that they do is they get with companies like us and they say, are you using the system properly? And we could look for something like that.
But since ITBD is using Halo, maybe you have that offering that we can do. I don't know, think about that. Like, hey, let me just do a review with you. Are you using this properly? That's one part. And the other part is for the NOC, do we need to relink our, you know, like when we had ConnectWise,
Mm.
Mhm.
We're going to help do a review of how your Halo is set up by someone who really knows what they're doing with Halo and kind of give us some feedback. And then the other part is, do we have some things we need to do with the NOC to get it put it to get it put in there?
So like connector is still active, I can see one ticket that is escalated to us.
It should not be, it should not be right, Ben. I think ConnectWise is no longer.
I mean, we still have ConnectWise, like 1 user, but we don't use it. I never log in. It's only used for like old stuff. So if it's connected to our ConnectWise, that's, we're never using it or looking at it.
Okay.
No, we hear you, we hear you, Ben, regarding the hello bot. Let me just look into this internally. We do have Helpdesk sitting with us, so...
So basically the transition.
Let me just check that internally and come back to you on that.
Okay, yeah, just...
Yeah.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, Vishal. And also, Ben, if you can just share, you know, a few pain points as per Halo, maybe your top five or top ten that can also help us, you know, we look internally, just like, just we just want to do our homework before we set up that call so that we can save your time and we are ready with all the answers. So if you can just give us top.
Mhm.
Five or top ten, as per your convenience. You can just share it over the email, or maybe you can just message me over Team Channel, and then we can look into it.
Okay.
Yeah, and then accordingly we can let you know.
Yeah, I'll get with Ashley on that. Ashley's doing pretty good on getting everything set up, but like, we're, it just, you know, so it might be nice to have, we're going on figuring it out as we go versus someone saying, oh, no, wait a minute, you're doing it this way. No, this is a better way to do it. You know, that's the kind of thing I'm looking for.
Let's take you.
Kip.
So what I'm hearing is it's just like a general check, right? Just to make sure that things are set up the way it should be. And if you do run into any roadblocks, then we can help you.
At first, yeah. And then if you guys identify any things that can be done better, you know, we could help us do that or what. But I mean, I feel like it's pretty good, but we still have things that, I don't know, like yesterday, this is not something that you guys would do.
Mm-hmm.
help with, but Ashley, like, I don't know, Mary Beth talked to you, but cost you put in some time and we could not figure out how to make it go to an invoice. Sit on there, ready to bill, boom, it never would show up, no matter what we did. That counts.
Yeah.
It.
Yep.
That, that's exactly what I'm looking for, you know, those pain points, you know, of yours, which we can, you know, help you.
Akshay.
Yeah.
I know, I will say that I think that the biggest pain point is Mary Beth having to deal with the billing because that's still, we're still working on that side and like making sure that.
Mm.
Yeah.
It it travels correctly to the right to the endpoint.
Yeah. All right, let's move on from that.
Fair enough. Yep. Yeah, you know, here's the funny part. You know, I was thinking it's like you bought a new car and you just want to make sure that the new car is working fine, right? You just want to take it to the person, you know, service guy, just to have a check and make sure that it's running great.
Yeah.
So, it's similar to the same thing, yeah, so, but we'll figure it out.
What we can do right now, I, you know, one immediate decision I would have, Addy, if you can just check with Gary, right, and just have someone from his team to just have a quick conversation with Ashley. I think, I don't see these are big, big changes or big problems that we are talking about. He just like, Ashley will have some generic questions, especially around billing.
So maybe someone from Gary team can just have a quick conversation and it could be a quick conversation, a quick resolution for her problem. So if you can just do that, that would be great.
Mm.
Yeah.
Like.
Yeah, sure, sure. Let me check then.
Thank you so much, Addy.
And from there onwards, we can see if you have some more concerns, some more problems that we need to address regarding Hello, and then we can just, you know, decide the way forward, Ben.
Rick.
OK.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you, Vishal. We have 16 minutes, so I'll quickly share my screen and we'll go through the presentation.
I.
All right, gentlemen. Ladies and gentlemen, I hope you can see my screen.
Okay, great. So welcome to our monthly service check-in for NTI networks. You look at May month's performance. Agenda item stays pretty much the same. We'll go through the highlights, performance analysis, holiday schedule, yeah by design, team GPS, way forward, and then meeting minutes. Highlights, as you all know, that
Yeah.
Akshay, he is now SC300 and AZ104 certified. Rachel is SC900 certified. They continue to work.
What's SC 300? What are the SC tests?
It's the security ones.
Security, okay.
Yeah, so I did I think I did share the certificate with you.
You told us, I think you told us. I don't know about the actual script, but...
Yeah, you told us about it last time.
Yeah, I think if you...
If you look at my email, there's a link. If you look at that, I mean, if you click that link, you'll get the certificate as well.
Okay.
Yeah, I just wanted to make sure that you were sharing it with your partners, users, just to make sure that the engineers are, you know, the engineer that they're working with are certified.
So this is security compliance and identity fundamentals Ben.
Yeah.
OK.
Okay, and rest, they continue to make sure that they are working on meeting the expectations and focusing on their KPIs. Before we move on to the next one, anything that you want to add, Jeremy, Ben, Megan, Lee? Ashley?
Nope, I thought on my end.
Yeah.
Okay, cool. Getting into the performance analysis.
Rachel, Akshay, they have been the rock star for me. I know Annie has been struggling, but from Rachel, Akshay perspective, they have been exceeding their numbers. So I think Ben, as we were discussing about how we can make sure that Annie is utilized, I had a connect with the...
Rachel and Akshay just to make sure if we can give her some kind of a checks, right, like device checks, infra checks so that she can work after hours when she has time to help the team. And I think that will definitely improve her utilization.
Yeah.
Yeah, I have a list of things, like I said, and when I'm done with that, it probably would be, I'll have a call with her and review unless you think we need more people, but I could probably just go through it with her and she'll have plenty of work to do.
Mhm.
Exactly, and I'm sure she has time after, you know, 5:00. Then, I mean, she's just waiting for the voice calls, right? Apart from that, that workload is not heavy, and I think she can very well manage all the checks. And then if she needs any help, then we can support her.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, as per the ticket closure rate, team has been doing fine with the closure rate. I don't have any, I don't see any major issues, but I think the only piece that we just want to cover is the checks for any. That's pretty much on my side. Going as per the holiday schedule, it looks good. I think the next one is July 3rd.
I'll follow up with Ashley and Jeremy close to July 3rd to see if you need.
No.
ITBD team on that day. Otherwise, you know, we can have everyone taking a day off on July 3rd.
S.
My third.
Apart from that, I haven't received any other PD requests. As soon as I get it, I'll share it with you.
Okay, rest, I just want to give a shout out to Jeremy, Ashley for being very supportive when it comes to PTOs and all the conversation that I keep on having offline on Team channel. I just want to say thank you so much for that.
I was.
All right, moving on shift schedule, it remains the same. They all know which, what shift they are supposed to cover. If it's the on call piece or the regular one, it stay the same. I don't see any change from your end, Ben, and any change that you see coming up, which I highly doubt.
Just wanted to check.
I think this is good, yeah.
All right.
Next up, we have our build it. We have discussed this last time, so I just wanted to reiterate. If it's feasible, we would love to have you during our build it. You have the code on the screen, QR, you can scan it, and you can reserve your seat.
And
Okay, we will cover Ayra by design.
You're coming to build it. You're coming to build it, Ben.
Yeah, we already have our tickets.
Yeah.
Great.
Great, because hello people would be there as well. So that would be great opportunity to interact. Just want to highlight that, yeah.
Okay.
Yes.
Great, thank you.
Okay, moving on quickly, as for the way forward, it remains the same. We just want to make sure that team is aligned with NTI Network's priorities and we are making the adjustments accordingly as we move forward. And that is pretty much it from my side. I'm going to stop sharing my screen. I'll go around the table.
I'll start with Megan.
Any questions, concerns, or feedback for us?
Ohh.
I really work a whole lot with the text. I'm just kind of here. But everything that I've seen from them has been good.
Right, we love to have you as always, Megan. We appreciate your feedback as well. So thank you so much. Ashley.
Nothing from me at this time.
Okay, cool. Thank you. Jerome.
Um...
I mean, the only thing I can really say is, you know, as usual, I'm always a resource for them if, you know, actually Rachel, Annie, if they ever need help for anything. I do just want to make sure that, you know, they are just really hammered into them that they're making sure to have the ticket updated and read through all the notes before contacting the client or asking me for help.
In.
Yes.
Because there's a lot of situation to which I'm not going to sugarcoat it. I get dumb questions for stuff that is kind of clearly spilled on the ticket. So it happens. I've done it too. Sometimes the answer is right in front of you and you just kind of just gloss over because you're in autopilot mode. The job can do it to you. As long as they're reading stuff and...
Mm.
Yeah.
You know.
Make sure they're calling the right numbers that are for the right people. And utilize the signatures is a kind of a big thing. I was talking to Meg about the whole thing, just kind of in relation to the whole calling the wrong number for someone that didn't even submit the ticket. Oftentimes a lot of our clients just have the phone numbers right there in their signatures.
Yeah.
Mhm.
I kind of want them to make sure that they're kind of borderline using that as their default rather than what's in Halo, because our Halo stuff is still, it's a work in progress. It's until we can kind of like fully confidently say that we are 100% where it's supposed to be. I want to make sure that they're using those.
Mm.
Understood.
Yeah.
when necessary.
That's a great point, Jerome, that you just made because we have the habit of checking ConnectWise, taking the number from there and then calling the user, right? We generally don't look at the signatures.
Um...
Mhm.
Yeah, yeah. Like I said, it's very easy to kind of go to autopilot on this whole thing, but it's just for the rest of us, it's just kind of common sense. We see you submitted the ticket through signature there. I'm probably going to use that one first before I will use whatever's in Halo or ConnectWise, you know, and so on. So, but otherwise, no.
Yeah.
Understood.
Yep.
Point noted.
That's about it. The guy's been doing fine. Everyone's been talking to me when they need help and stuff, and I'm kind of pointing in the right direction. So they're doing good.
Awesome. Thank you. Thank you, Jeremy. And point noted. I'll just make sure that I reiterate the same, and hopefully you'll see the improvement. Thank you so much for the feedback. Appreciate it. Ben, over to you.
Of course.
I already had all my feedback at the beginning, so nothing else from me.
Okay, cool. Addy, anything from your end?
No coming, I'm good. Thank you.
Thanks, Andy.
Thank you, Evan. Hello, everyone. Sorry for joining the meeting late. I missed the initial feedback part and I'll collect that from Kavan. And just wanted to ensure that when you have the hotel link for booking the rooms, the block we have.
Open it.
Oh, my very best handling that for me, so I'm sure she does.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Like, that was a query I have. Thank you, thank you everyone.
The block, I have not gotten an email about that because I'll need to book one too. Thank you.
I'll send you the link. I'll send.
Yeah, send us the link because we need to go get go ahead and get our rooms.
Yeah, and all that stuff, yeah.
Right, I'll send it right to them. Thank you.
Yeah.
Awesome. Thank you. Thank you, Andy, for covering that. I actually missed that piece, so thank you so much.
Yeah, that's coming up.
Mmhmm.
Yeah.
Okay, Vishal, how about you?
I'm all good, Kavan. Thank you so much. Thank you, Ben, Ashley, Megan, for your time. Thank you, Jeremy.
Yep.
Okay, thank you, Vishal. Well, ladies and gentlemen, I gave you 6 minutes back. So thank you so much for the time today. Thank you so much for joining in. We'll speak to you next month. Till then, have a good one. Take care. Bye bye. Bye bye.
Thank you.
Well.
Awesome. Thank you guys. Bye bye.
Take care. Thanks, guys. Bye.
Alright, bye.